hello I'm Tom Dworkin president of the
Committee to Protect Journalists
recently after viciously body-slamming a
member of the press
Montana congressman Greg Jian Forte made
a $50,000 donation to our nonprofit the
incident was tragic and yet $50,000 is
so much money which is why we've created
a new fundraising program called
beat the press it's simple a body slam
is just a $50,000 donation but there's
more you can whip a reporter with your
belt or perform an elbow drop you can
hit a reporter with a folding chair then
tag in another member of Congress we've
got options for more budget minded
assailants
[Music]
or you can become one of our gold
medallion donors by choosing from elite
packages like throwing a body from a
moving car defenestration or refin
astray we're the committee to protect
journalists and any attack on the Free
Press comes at a price
beginning at about two hundred and fifty
dollars can we get a more realistic
dummy I don't think that's asking a lot
that was that dummy that they were
tossing around was a suit of clothes
that they stuff like three socks until
that but that dummy is one of our prop
guys brother-in-law it has no
musculature
you